you are like every time you come in here
you look so Dapper so so much you look
great too well someone a whole team of
people makes this happen I don't look
like this in general well same no I feel
like you probably look like this at
Target okay I appr I appreciate your
optimism when it comes to my how I look
you totally do probably but wait so New
Year's just Happ how do you celebrate
New Year's I have absolutely no
expectations for New Year I have no list
no bar I have no I call them like at the
very because what is it New Year
resolutions yeah do you do those no
obviously not I tried every year you try
and every year you fail not to be a
fatalist but I'm just terrible at them I
don't like to say fail I like to say
just not there yet right right right
right working on it we're working it um
I don't love to work on things so I'm
just I love working on things yes so you
stick to a list I will stick to the list
and it doesn't matter if it takes a
decade but I'm still doing it yeah I
just like to have I like goals I like
yeah yeah well I also now like goals and
want to set them for myself I do I I
don't know why I think it gives me
purpose like to go like okay this is the
thing I'm going I did a thing last year
where I said okay I was going to walk
every day and I was going to add like an
extra five minutes every time I walked
okay yeah and then 15 days
later I am on my couch yeah yeah yeah
there's no hiking there's no nothing and
the shoes are just sitting by my front
door I do like hiking you're from the
most beautiful place ever Canada is so
beautiful to hike it is very yeah yeah
didn't col
either just a hard no I love it so wait
you and your dad are both part of it's
called The Order of Canada right I
talked about this with your dad you're
now both a part of it yeah this is a big
deal in Canada I it is it's like I don't
it's like I don't know am I a night now
like I don't know what that is I think
so I'm going to just be kned I guess is
what it comes down to you know it's like
a great honor I will say yes it's like a
tremend honor and I don't want to
discredit Canada obviously but my dad
has been on here so many times that I
feel like that has been the great honor
and now it's my on top of like I should
be wearing my pin actually a I love your
dad he's he loves you so much I ditto I
love him so much that is the great honor
I mean you know a country recognizing
you is great um but being here is also
great uh I love has anybody is is there
is there ever in the Order of Canada is
there like a father son or a mother
daughter I actually have no idea I think
that you might be the first I'm just
saying it let's just say we're the first
let's just say it yeah breaking glass
feeling I like it I like it I think you
get another one when that happens yes I
think you're just a special special
member you get another record sort of
right at the end just on the bottom
[Music]
[Applause]
page
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home